hi i'm making this video to challenge
the canadian government to try to stop
me before i
go through with my horrendous plan to
fight every single endangered species on
your list
i'm not gonna kill them don't get me
wrong i'm not gonna kill them
but if they happen to die they die and
if i die
they die it's all a fair fight and
they're in danger because canada let me
into the country
and that is their mistake and the
equivalent of the canadian fbi
has all the fair warning that they need
in this video to come arrest me so that
i can make the speed run world record
for getting arrested by the canadian fbi
and or government which is who i need to
ask
canada fbi csis is canada's lead agency
on national security matters for
conducting national security
investigations and security intelligence
collection
okay that sounds more like the csi cis
cis
csi cs i ciscs
cis the cia
but that's not the fbi it's our fbi in
canada
what's this version of cia yeah that's
the cia
fbi the royal canadian mounted police
really really that's their fbi
whoa royal canadian
mounted police holy [ __ ]
i know about the mounties i didn't know
that that was their equivalent of the
fbi
holy crap i mean i knew not to mess with
these dudes like these dudes
these dudes you don't mess look at that
chin look at the jaw
look at the jaw my god
this is a handsome squidward okay
so my challenge is how fast can i get
arrested by
the royal canadian mounted police so
this is just a question of how many
endangered animals could i get through
in a battle a fair battle to the death
before they come and stop
me because i think the punishment for
killing like an endangered species which
i'm not trying to do
i'm just trying to beat them to teach
them a lesson
so it's all fair like i think it's like
something like five years in prison so
for every animal that i beat you know
another five years
i'm trying to collect them like pokemon
cards okay so the common loon
this is the common loon for you don't
know cool bird like real
neat duck like that's a sweet ass duck
look at the red eye
look at the baby baby oh do you get your
red eye
when they kill their first kill they get
the red eye that's so cool
okay so if i was to battle this bird
okay number one there they've got
clearly some piercing abilities um
so a frontal assault isn't going to do
me any good uh i think their one
weakness is that
they float on the water and i with my
dense dense bones would be able to float
below the water
so i would sneak up on them like a
crocodile and i would just pick one eye
up to keep an eye on
or i wouldn't even need to do this i
would just open my eyes underneath the
creek water with all the poop and the
amoebas
and i would sacrifice my eyesight
because i know i'm not going to last
very long with all these animals that
i'm going to try to fight
and i would sneak up below it and then i
would just upwards motion
i have a lot of ability to generate
force in a forwards and upwards
direction
so i would be able to kick off the
bottom of the creek bed
with a rising uppercut but i would
actually shape my hand like a dagger
this has to be hand-to-hand combat no
tools
like if i were to use tools it would be
unfair i have to beat them with what is
in my body
and on my body and using my body to
drive my body which i would do i would
kick
forward and upward with all of my
kicking forward upward ability
which is probably my strongest ability
and i would drive my fist
in a dagger-like formation straight up
through
through its body and i would hopefully
be able to grab its heart
on the way in and then punch through i
would
smash up with my forward upward lunging
grab its heart push through
and then rip downwards into the depths
where which i would win the fight so
this is this is gonna
like it it all rides on my ability to be
very sneaky
um but to be perfectly honest they spend
too much of their time laughing
maniacally at how great they are
obviously you know they look both ways
to try to protect their baby but they're
not looking down
they're not looking down below here
below the surface also not the national
bird anymore
the national bird is now this thing by
the way if you didn't know
this pathetic piece of [ __ ] you know
this isn't even going to be a fight you
know i get one hand around and just
squeeze hard and it just one squeak and
it's gone
i'm not trying to kill these animals
it's not what i'm about here
peace and love but also fight to the
death if
it comes to that it's really if they tap
out beforehand
but this isn't even a fight this isn't
even a fight so i have a list of
endangered species
in canada and and a lot of these you
know are going to be able to put up a
good fight summer
orca okay that's that's going to be
tough one that that is really going to
be a tough one
a lot of my forward and upwards ability
to drive at that is kind of negated by
the fact that it's a [ __ ] orca
but i'm getting ahead of myself let's
let's uh let's start let's start from
the bottom
okay marmot okay easy is this one of the
things that digs in the ground
size of a large house cat oh my god easy
crush it between my
thighs what's being done what can i do
uh i can fight it
oh okay dens in rocky slopes with loose
soils and lots of sedimentation from
rainwater
it's a calluvial dweller what is a
colluvial dweller
the frick is a colluvial dweller what
the frick is this what is this
what is what is that what
what is that what is that
in the gulf dweller in the gulf what
happened to your eyes bro
what happened to your eyes
okay i can't wait to fight against that
i'm not even going to try
screw that noise is that protected by is
this it says colluvial dweller and
that's what this pops up
is this like the evolution like a
pokemon evolution of this thing
that turns into a colluvial dweller oh
my god
um okay pass okay i'm gonna pass on that
one
you know you you get a pass i can't risk
that kind of transformation
i really can't okay so caribou right so
caribou is just a dumb moose
when it comes to a smart moose you know
that's going to be a real challenge
but a dumb moose is easy so so all you
got to do is bull fighter style i'm
going to stand by a tree
and it's going to come charging at me
and all i have to do is go
whoop and then it hits the tree and dies
like that's pretty much it or gets
knocked out unconscious you know because
not lethal
so this is really like this is a simple
fight that's not even a matchup okay
wolverine
the [ __ ] is a wolverine doing in canada
i thought that was like in tasmania or
something like that
no that's a tasmanian devil is a
wolverine actually a real thing
skunk bear good god marks its food
with urine and musk it pees on its food
a fluid secreted by its anal glands and
glutton because of a variation at what
why do you piss on your food you deserve
to
what is wrong with you good god okay
so powerful teeth and jaws are adapted
for crushing the frozen meat they
scavenged in winter
uh so i'm gonna counter this by just
making myself as squishy as possible
so clearly their jaws are meant for more
hard substances they probably have the
power to crush rocks
so what i'm gonna do is i'm to load up
on a lot of haagen-dazs and i'm going to
make myself as squishy and bouncy as
possible
it's going to be like those anime
villains where when the hero who's
really good at punching and martial arts
punches
and then they find that their fist just
gets like bounced off of the rotund
belly so i'm going to laugh at it
because what's going to happen is like
it's going to try to pee on me
it's got like the musk but i will not
have showered in like 20 years
leading up to this fight i am willing to
do whatever it takes to prepare for this
and i will hide in the detricus of their
own food and then i will leap out and
when they try to
bite me all their jaws and bones will
just like ricochet off they'll literally
all of it will be absorbed by my immense
mass and
i will simply fall on top of them
because they will stand their ground and
they will yell at me and i will just be
like timber a [ __ ]
and gone okay whooping cranes
i give whooping cough easy done win uh
whip poor will i don't even know what
i'm looking at what am i looking at what
animal is this
this is a bird lazarus in synchrony with
the lunar cycle allows the eggs to hatch
about 10 days before a full moon giving
parents time to gather as much as food
as possible for the chicks often just
okay well okay this is easy
uh i'm actually going to ruin the entire
species here i'll blow up the moon
um and then they will never know when to
lay their eggs and then they will never
reproduce a single generation and
they're going to be gone
if there's no moon they can't reproduce
that's their stupid fault for being
based on the lunar cycle
uh there can't be any eggs laid if you
can't be in synchronicity with a bunch
of dust
in space because i blew up the moon okay
the psi whale the s-e-i whale
the saiy whale okay whale's gonna be
tough
they lived 74 years okay so i have a
chance to outlive it
technically that's beating it okay so
i'm just gonna live very healthy
i'm gonna live a very healthy life i'm
gonna pick which one i'm gonna fight
based on one that is matched up in terms
of age with me
and it will be an endurance race if it
can catch me and i can catch it we can
fight each other but because
it's based in the water and i hate the
ocean i will never go in the water and
then i will just live a very healthy
very careful life
and then once it dies then i can die
immediately afterwards and this is like
the oldest age recorded
and i'm korean so i got a lot on my side
on this one win for me
put that in my book i won that one rusty
blackbird
okay so it feeds on insects right
insects and worms is that what it said
okay so what i do this one's actually
kind of easy all i do is i do the like
got your nose trick but i just
i paint this to look like a worm and
when the when it dives towards
this to try to eat it i punch it and
then by punch it i cave it skull in
and then it just falls down to the
ground and this is like an easiest one
this would be the quickest one actually
i'll just paint this like a worm and be
like oh who wants dinner
and then you're dead the poor beagle
shark
oh god no another doesn't even have a
picture it's just the ocean
it's 12 feet long no
this might be my first loss okay it
doesn't exist uh
so this thing's a myth i i think i win
by default it didn't show up to the
fight
uh therefore you know i think uh this
means i won uh
piri calibu caribou bailey caribou
man this is tough god there's got to be
an easier law it's the easiest
law to break in canada crazy sloths
canadians break every day without
realizing it okay illegal to ice skate
on any road in wetaskiwin
alberta okay you can face a fine if your
cat damages any plants and okay that's
not
near me two bagpipers legally cannot
perform on city streets at the same time
it is against the law to park within 200
meters of an active fire
okay a game in any municipal parking lot
in red
okay any game like a nintendo switch
legal to whistle or sing at any given
time in mars lake
okay not allowed to have an internet
[Music]
what what what
okay so i just have a fast internet i be
i'm watching netflix in my bathtub with
five inches of water in it all right so
i'm taking a bath out in a public
bathtub that i brought out there
i just got done building a snow a
snowman
that's 40 inches and then i i'm playing
an online game on my nintendo switch
using an internet connection that's
faster than 56k this is how i get there
after i remove my bandages it's illegal
to consume
fake maple syrup all right so i'm
chugging corn syrup based maple syrup
in a bathtub of five inches of water
after building a 40 inch snowman
playing my nintendo switch online with a
faster than 56k
modem while removing my bandages that's
how i get a wrist
super super fast oh man how many laws
does it take before they come
get me before those handsome mounted
police come
get me okay which which animals could
beat me up
that's the question right like the heron
god damn that would that would probably
just like dive bomb right through me and
just look
right right through my heart the perky
caribou
i don't know about that but i don't like
the name perky uh
this gives me some heebie-jeebies about
it and i don't like the way it's looking
at the camera there
the kangaroo rat is that the one that
screams lexie and put in a clip of it
screaming
ah another one
okay so orca you know orcas they don't
typically want to eat
humans but you know i guess if i
challenged it to a fight
you know it would probably want to throw
down or it probably wouldn't be opposed
to throwing down
so i guess a bird eat it uh another duck
uh punch it grizzly bear i'd die greater
sage groose
i think i'd lose that fight i think i
would lose it gray fox i
literally like turned it inside out i'd
reach inside its anus and i would pull
its entire
body inside out the frugalness
the ferruganes the forugenus hawk
no i'd lose uh eastern cougar i'd seduce
it a common nighthawk
um i'd seduce it collard pika
pokeball uh master ball actually uh
canadian warbler
i'd out warble it i would have a
screaming match it'd be like
two sound waves going to bounce against
each other and then eventually its head
would just
burrowing out my forward and upward
ability to thrust
all i have to do is launch upside down
and suddenly my forward and upward is
is backwards and downwards and i'd go
right into the ground i'd meet it on its
own turf and i would just destroy it
uh buff breasted sandpiper i would buff
your
breasts out of existence with a
sandpaper grinder [ __ ]
meet me in the field bobo link your
name's stupid
uh blanding's turtle more like boring's
bland
you're [ __ ] boring i'd eat you i
hammer no uh fist no i
i can't use tools uh i'd blow up the
moon again
uh black-footed ferret dip its feet in
white paint then it's a different
species then i have one
uh beard sparrow more like dad's dead
sparrow american badger why are you even
in canada get the [ __ ] out of here
endangered species this is
this is the species known as endangered
species you know honestly if i had to go
up a bear
of a bear which its name was endangered
species i would be very afraid i think
that would not turn out well for me
all right so it looks like uh it looks
like once i fight these species
i should be able to get arrested pretty
quickly i think that it's pretty clear
that i would win
most of these matchups at great cost to
the surrounding environments like the
moon being blown up and all that stuff
but worth it if it's just to allow me to
actually fight some of these things
um i look forward to the royal canadian
mounted police to bashing down my door
oh i think that's them now so i'm gonna
go before they uh come around
me i'll be with you in just a second
hold on i'll be right with you so i'm
gonna be
uh gone for a like like a long time i
think this is probably gonna stack up
but i haven't done anything yet it's
locked you can't get in
um yeah so um i'm gonna have to go i
gotta go real quick uh
like the video subscribe for more cool
content yeah uh-huh yeah uh-huh
uh-huh okay yeah but yeah i'm finishing
up
okay yeah i don't have any weapons no no
i don't
yeah so uh i'll be i'll be gone um i'll
see you guys around when i get out of
canadian prison
take care good luck to you and as always
i will see you
in the next week
you